[Music]
on this wednesday night the facts about
canada's supply chain problem
a convoy of truckers heading to ottawa
claims the vaccine mandate is to blame
but where's the evidence the idea to
reduce the supply chains issues to a
vaccine mandate is is inaccurate and
it's false we look at what's led to some
empty shelves at grocery stores how
canada is supporting ukraine everything
we do is motivated by our pursuit of
de-escalation and no concessions nato
and russia hold firm to their positions
we're ready either way and we look at
the messaging from the kremlin to the
russian public
cleared for takeoff the air car gets the
green light in slovakia
[Music]
global national with donna friesen
[Music]
good evening and thanks for joining us
we begin with a look at what's causing
empty shelves and low stock in some
grocery stores industry experts agree
the country is not running out of food
there is no crisis but there is a lot of
blame going around about the root cause
of problems with the supply chain
among the loudest voices is the
self-described freedom convoy that's
heading to ottawa its supporters blame
the government call public health
restrictions unlawful and claim the
vaccine mandate for cross-border
truckers has reduced the supply of goods
they have a whole host of other
grievances too some even calling for the
government to be overthrown
well a couple of important points the
majority of canadian truckers are
vaccinated and the u.s has the same
vaccine mandate for cross-border
truckers it's not just canada tonight
david aiken has a reality check on
what's causing the supply chain problem
many in the convoy say they've had
enough with vaccine mandates a lot of
people are trying to say that these
types of things are done out of anger
but this is actually being done under
frustration towards the things that the
the government is imposing upon canadian
citizens and federal conservatives are
lining up squarely behind this protest
blaming the trudeau government's vaccine
mandate for truckers for grocery store
shelves that may not look like they
normally do on wednesday trudeau's
transport minister rejected those claims
it's it's misguided at best it is
irresponsible at worst to be promoting
fear and panic among canadians that our
food supply is at risk the ceo of one of
the country's major grocery store chains
metro confirmed that view in an investor
call tuesday though the ceo said the
vaccine mandate may push some prices up
on the vaccination of truckers um it's
having or will have mostly an
inflationary impact on the cost of uh
merchandise coming in from the u.s
produce especially
uh we we saw an uptick in in the
transportation costs right away but
we're getting the merchandise
so
our transportation providers are able to
service us in fact the biggest problem
causing product shortages right now is
omicron forcing employees to stay off
the job be it on the farm in the
warehouse or in grocery stores the
pandemic slowed things down across the
supply chain but omicron was a huge blow
to the food industry
you have to really operate and do the
same things with
way fewer people around so the idea
to reduce the supply chains issues to a
vaccine mandate is is inaccurate and
it's false
and then there's the problems the convoy
itself may cause disrupting national
highways canadians support truckers but
i i don't i don't believe they they
support the convoy because the convoy is
creating some disruptions
and that's the last thing we need right
now meanwhile police responsible for
parliament hill are preparing for the
arrival this weekend of possibly
hundreds of big rigs many they expect
will be filled with angry truckers david
aiken global news ottawa
now to the tension over ukraine prime
minister justin trudeau has authorized
the deployment of more canadian troops
to ukraine as it resists what he calls
unwarranted russian aggression 60 more
troops will be sent now to join 200
already on operation unifier in ukraine
the number could increase to 400 in the
months ahead and unlike some of our
allies canada will be sending non-lethal
equipment only
today i've authorized the extension of
operation unifier for three more years
and the expansion of this training
mission as well as immediate support
this also includes a provision of
non-lethal equipment intelligence
sharing and support to combat cyber
attacks
the prime minister says canada is
supplying non-lethal equipment only
because the solution to the standoff is
diplomatic the ukrainian government
though has asked for weapons in an
exclusive interview the secretary of
ukraine's national security and defense
council told global news the threat from
russia's president is worldwide he
points to the poisoning of enemies of
vladimir putin and cyber attacks on
sovereign nations
our europe bureau chief crystal
gemensing spoke with him crystal
ukraine is expressing its gratitude to
canada for its economic and ongoing
military training support but the
country's national security chief also
says right now his country's needs are
clear
it's defense weapons
defense weapons
and once more defense weapons
the united states and the uk have sent
military supplies including weapons to
ukraine as anxieties remain over whether
the nation of 44 million will be plunged
into another war with russia
alexi danilov says only the kremlin
knows for sure
he cautions world leaders from using the
number of russian troops on the border
as a gauge military science is much more
complicated than just amounts of people
those
people in uniform who are standing on
the border is he worried about cyber
attacks is he worried about terrorist
attacks that could take out key
infrastructure
say islamic
[Music]
and then in numerous directions in which
aggression can be carried out
in kiev talk of war turns to prayer and
appeals for calm
nothing has changed i took 10 onions as
i usually do
no need to panic whatever is said or not
said whatever is done or not done
while ukraine calls for defense supports
russia released another dramatic
military operations video and a ruling
party official said russia should next
arm ethnic russian separatists in
eastern ukraine the families of canadian
diplomats here in ukraine have been told
to go home along with those at the
american and uk embassies oleksi danilov
says he understands those people have a
home to go back to for ukrainians this
is home and so if called upon they will
fight for their country
donna
all right crystal commencing in ukraine
tonight thanks efforts to use diplomacy
instead of conflict to resolve the
tension there are continuing tonight the
u.s and its allies have delivered
written responses to russian demands for
security guarantees over nato expansion
but say there will be no concessions
russia wants assurances that ukraine and
georgia will never be allowed to join
nato and has said refusal to do so will
amount to an aggression jackson proskow
has the latest on where things stand
it was the u.s ambassador in moscow who
hand delivered the response to russia's
demands outlining the american position
on a path forward
as russia continued its massive military
buildup near ukraine we've laid out a
diplomatic path
we've lined up steep consequences should
russia choose further aggression it
remains up to russia to decide how to
respond
we're ready either way
what exactly the u.s offered isn't known
but there were no major concessions
moscow has vowed what it calls necessary
retaliatory measures if its demands
aren't met that includes clawing back
the size of nato and stopping countries
like ukraine from joining the alliance
in this fragile moment ukrainian
officials warn russia may be plotting
something other than a full-fledged
invasion what we currently see is a
scenario of destabilization of ukraine
and that scenario is certainly imminent
overnight more american weaponry was
shuttled into kiev the u.s and its
allies are now considering an immediate
deployment of troops to nato's eastern
flank instead of waiting for russia to
act first
tensions are increasing
russia continues its military buildup we
call on russia once again to immediately
de-escalate the situation
instead russian president vladimir putin
continues to drop hints about the levers
he could pull in a conflict in a meeting
with italian business leaders he
stressed the importance of russian gas
supplies to europe a tap he could easily
turn off during any conflict the u.s
insists it did make serious offers for a
diplomatic de-escalation but the
russians have signaled little appetite
for what they consider endless
discussions
asked how he thought putin would respond
to the american proposal the u.s
secretary of state replied we'll see
donna
jackson in washington thanks the view
from inside russia is much different
than in the west russia's highly
developed propaganda machine is working
overtime and russian state tv and social
media are presenting a different picture
to the russian people as jeff semple
explains the narrative may reveal clues
about moscow's broader strategy
[Music]
russian state tv can provide a window
into the kremlin the networks are tasked
with telling vladimir putin's preferred
version of events but what's perhaps
most remarkable about their coverage
these days is what they're not talking
about i don't perceive a lot of
war preparations not in the rhetoric on
state tv this canadian ukrainian
journalist has lived in russia for 35
years he remembers the war mongering
prior to russia's invasion of georgia in
2008 an annexation of crimea in 2014.
back then russian tv screens were
dominated by images of violent
ukrainians overthrowing their
pro-russian government but fred weir
says this time is different the tone in
state tv is the hope for peace i i just
don't
see
the the war mongering
that is imputed to to russia there's
virtually nothing about
the military maneuvers and
much of the coverage has focused instead
on diplomacy on putin the great
statesman forcing the americans to the
table
in that situation the russian regime can
present itself as
as strong international power as a power
that wants peace but is ready to defend
itself rasmus nilsson says that's likely
due to russia's national mood opinion
polls show ordinary russians do not want
war with ukraine
this independent russian pollster says
that russians are completely opposed to
war they want a diplomatic solution but
they also believe that the west will
stop at nothing to push keeve to attack
russian separatists in eastern ukraine
that belief is fueled in part by
headlines like these claiming without
evidence that keeve and nato plan to
attack russian-speaking communities in
eastern ukraine analysts warn this
propaganda is designed to convince
russians that the kremlin has no choice
but to intervene in ukraine for the
classic classic false flag that we're
moving now because they are preparing an
attack
and to save our fellow russians from
ukrainian aggression we have no other
alternative
but but but to do this a potential
russian military invasion of eastern
ukraine being sold as a humanitarian
rescue mission to defend a
russian-speaking population against
attacks from the west
jeff semple global news
in the uk prime minister boris johnson
is still in power but the pressure to
resign because of parties held during
lockdown is getting even more intense
we've taken the tough decisions we've
got the big calls right and we're and in
particular i am getting on with the job
he's waiting for results not just of an
internal investigation but a police
investigation too it was thought the
internal report by a top civil servant
into boozy parties at downing street
during lockdown might be released today
it hasn't been leaving johnson to sweat
several of his conservative mps have
said they're waiting for the findings
before deciding if they'll join calls
for him to step down
a new brunswick doctor takes on facebook
coming up the implications of a lawsuit
against the social media giant
[Music]
tonight we're taking a closer look at a
lawsuit that could have implications for
social media platforms it centers on a
new brunswick doctor who says he was
wrongly accused of causing a covet 19
outbreak that resulted in the death of
two people he's suing the new brunswick
government the rcmp and facebook for
allegedly allowing hateful messages to
circulate ross lord reports on the
implications of that lawsuit
dr jean robert angola says he feels
betrayed not only by new brunswickers
who blamed him for violating covet-19
rules and spreading the virus but also
by facebook for allowing racist
threatening messages to circulate online
facebook must block that
dutch samples first because we must
block that angola alleges the hateful
messages were shared thousands of times
around the world causing him to fear for
his life
his lawsuit pursues punitive damages of
three percent of facebook meta net
profits with the company's net annual
income estimated at more than 86 billion
dollars the claim could be worth a
fortune his lawyers say it's time for
the company to recognize the destruction
and devastation that their actions
caused going after facebook in court is
a recent development the tendency of
people to see them now as a viable
defendant is new this constitutional law
specialist says it's partly because of
whistleblower francis haugen who
suggested facebook meta is fixated on
profit at the expense of safety
american-based court challenges have
been thwarted by free speech protections
but in canada there are stronger limits
on things like the racist attacks and
alleged threats hurled at angola that's
the very first section of our
constitution that all the rights in the
charter are subject to reasonable limits
including the free speech rights which
almost certainly will be a key defense
that facebook will put forward in this
case others say angola's case could
establish how much responsibility social
media platforms should take in helping
protect and not damage people's
well-being i do think we need more
regulation for social media companies
they hold extraordinary
power in our communities they're the
main way that we engage in public
dialogue in a statement facebook meta
says it doesn't comment on pending
litigation
ross lord global news
the bank of canada is holding its
benchmark interest rates steady but
warns it will rise despite surging
inflation the central bank is keeping
its key lending rate at 0.25 percent
that's the same level it's been since
this onset of the pandemic the bank's
governor says uncertainty about omicron
is one of the key reasons to hold it
steady but don't expect that to last
as the pandemic fades conditions will
normalize and inflation will come down
however with canadian labor markets
tightening and evidence of capacity
pressures increasing
governing council
expects higher interest rates will be
needed to bring inflation back to the
two percent target
the u.s federal reserve also held its
key interest rates steady today and
signaled a hike could come as early as
march
ahead a major rescue off spain's canary
islands saves hundreds
more than 300 migrants rescued from the
ocean have arrived in spain they were
saved after seven boats got into trouble
off the canary islands officials say
some people were found clinging to a
capsized boat most of the people are
believed to be from northern and central
africa there are reports at least 18
others did not survive the ordeal but no
bodies have been recovered
and a search is underway off the coast
of florida where a boat suspected in
human smuggling capsized in a storm the
u.s coast guard is scouring the water
for 38 people at least one body has been
found and another person was rescued
after he was spotted clinging to an
overturned boat he says the group left
the bahamian island of bimini about 80
kilometers east of miami on saturday
night
no one was wearing a life jacket the u.s
has launched a criminal investigation
in syria u.s backed kurdish-led forces
have regained full control of a prison a
week after it was seized by so-called
islamic state militants syrian
democratic forces took back control of
the last section of the prison today
freeing a number of child detainees who
were used as human shields the brazen
assault is the group's most high profile
isis attack since the loss of their
so-called caliphate in 2019. dozens of
fighters on both sides were killed and
thousands of people living nearby have
been displaced
wheels up next where this flying car is
taking flight
it's been a science fiction staple for
decades a vehicle that can seamlessly
take you from the road to the sky
all kinds of companies are now working
on flying cars it's a highly competitive
race and in slovakia regulators have
actually given one car the green light
mike dralet reports
when people talk about flying cars the
jetsons come to mind or chitty chitty
bang bang
i prefer james bond the man with the
golden gun
no he had something better the car the
sprouted wings climb vision's air car
has that same vibe from soaring in the
skies high above europe to landing in an
airstrip it's clearly a plane but in
three minutes all those flying parts get
tucked away leaving a sports car it's
not one thing or the other is it a
flying car or a roadable aircraft
it's a flying car well actually it's a
flying car that's now been certified as
airworthy in the heart of europe by the
slovakian state transport agency
it's a bit confusing but it basically
allows someone to land the car in any
european jurisdiction that gives it the
green light and which also has a landing
strip this might be good to go from your
larger
multi-hectare estate to another
multi-hectare state or a small airport
but really uh that saw some of the
limitations between some of these some
of these new kinds of uh you know quote
unquote flying vehicles now the flying
car market is surprisingly saturated
everybody seems to have their own idea
of what it will look like
some think the future will look more
like the lilium jet or the volocopter
both of which are more air taxi than
flying car the canadian-made black fly
is neither it's a personal aerial
vehicle which is just really cool but
that's not the market anton zajac is
interested in he's all about finding a
way around that morning commute uh
traffic is driving me crazy
uh when i go skiing i i can't ski when i
have to
wait in line so i i just quick quit
skiing i just hate lines maybe because i
used to live in a communist country and
you would have to wait for everything
you know yeah we know traffic sucks so
why not just take off
mike drolite global news toronto
that is global national for this
wednesday i'm donna friesen tonight's
here canada is this view from gross
mountain in north vancouver there are
beautiful spots all over canada please
email us yours to viewers at
globalnational.com
thanks for watching hope to see you here
again tomorrow take care of yourselves
bye-bye
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
you